all right there's a new place in
henderson where you can satisfy your
sweet or savory taste buds let us
introduce you to mochi nut
[Music]
mochi nut is a brand new franchise out
of california expanding at a pretty
rapid rate famous for mochi style donuts
and korean rice hot dogs mochi donut is
a relatively new style of donut that
combines rice flour with a traditional
style donut which gives it a really
light and fluffy yet chewy type of
texture and it is a fusion between asian
and hawaiian culture and that's where it
first started the hawaiian mochi donut
obviously made its way over here to las
vegas our flavors here at mochina change
about twice a week we like to post our
flavors of the week on instagram so make
sure to follow us at mochi nut
underscore henderson and most classic
flavors that we keep on a regular basis
are going to be our churro our
strawberry and our cookies and cream
we also have some flavors that are for
the more adventurous type like ube and
matcha with oreo and right now our most
popular flavor is our new 9th island
flavor which blends passion fruit with
mango and it's topped with a little bit
of coconut well here at mochi nut we
also have a korean style rice hot dogs
which are very similar to a traditional
corn dog just not as heavy on the batter
we use the same sort of rice flour base
to give it a light and fluffy interior
but we coat it with panko to give it a
crispy exterior they come in many
varieties
we do original which is 100 all beef hot
dog we do half hot dog half mozzarella
we even do half a whole mozzarella as
well and they also can come with a
variety of toppings that we like to
change it up with hot cheetos potato or
crispy ramen to give it a little bit of
a
different texture on the outside but
it's still going to be light and fluffy
but super crispy on the outside and a
lot of fun for the kids as well on top
of the korean rice hot dogs we recommend
a wide variety of sauces that we also
make in-house
we do a garlic mayo
we do a mango habanero as well sriracha
mayo and we also do a cheddar cheese
sauce that is very popular as well so we
definitely have a wide variety of sauces
to make your corn dog special just for
you we also serve fresh lemonade that we
make in-house every day classic flavors
like mango strawberry but we also have
some
flavors out of hawaii like lychee and
guava as well make sure you guys come on
down to mochi nut and henderson we're in
the smiths parking lot just off of the
exit of valley verde and 2 15 and we're
open 11 a.m to 7 p.m every single day so
make sure to come on down grab a donut a
dog and a fresh lemonade and make sure
you mention that you saw us on las vegas
now and you come by you get a free mochi
donut
and we'll see you guys soon
mochi nut henderson is open 7 days a
week 11 a.m to 7 p.m they are located at
55 south valle verde drive suite 410 in
henderson you can give them a call at
702
702-413-6456 or visit
mochinethenderson.com
also you can submit catering or larger
orders to mochinut henderson gmail.com
and they have a special offering for you
you just have to mention las vegas now
and you'll receive a free emoji donut of
your choice with any purchase